ma il colle iter chapelle più tardi
lavare luego chiamerò più tardi in tutte
le lingue c'era scritto chiamerò più
tardi
bene tutti ragazzi minuti questo video
sono fallite oggi siamo su penombra c'è
questo si chiama penombra e non è in
c'entra niente col penombra storico
penombra quello che facevo io quando lo
facevo i video è molto più bianco
andiamo a vedere cosa si tratta di cosa
si tratta rogato per il signor gioco
horror perché si chiama penombra e
sicuramente un gioco horror mi piace che
sfarfallano le luci all'inizio perché
vuol dire che manco la però un gettone
che mi porta volentieri per le giostre
perché vedo che questo è un posto molto
carina se sembra proprio all'inizio di
penombra tra l'altro anche in chip
londra inizia così con la neve che
figata ai ragazzi sei un nuovo horror
novità e non portavo un no non è vero
noi a da una vita però che c'è una
pagina che sembra il costo di sopra lo
prendo a non la prendo scherzava andiamo
lì sotto la trama di penombra e racket o
in travi in questa specie di bunker
sotterraneo in antartide una roba se
c'erano cose non so se è proprio la
stessa cosa però ma soprattutto dietro
questo con visioni luci da è diamo
avanti a caso va bene ho sentito il
rumore ho vinto qualcosa
ma devi fare il giro della devo girare
la colonna devo fare il giro è la
colonna è giusto ora devo spostare la
colonna cos'è sta roba è comparsa tra
l'altro sarà la prima non c'era forse
dall'altra parte solo genio ma cavolo è
fatto benissimo è comparsa una scala
proprio come quella della mia vita che
mi porta in alto e mi fa capire che ogni
giorno arrivò al successo non è vero
sono intrappolati in un labirinto evo
devo seguire esattamente gli ordini va
bene per due
devo citare due volte intorno giusto 1 e
tua sorella
salve aiuto regia due volte si si
continua a girare
ho fatto è successo
oh mio dio no vabbè ragazzine bellissimo
un gioco fantastico sono dei gettoni
prendili ci sono anche delle fiamme per
aria buongiorno a vado a fuoco
salve le va a fuoco se n'è accorto le
russe n'è accorto ma va a fuoco ma vai a
fuoco per i fatti tuoi bravissimo mi
piace questo gioco e allegro dai fuoco
alle cose io sono un piromane
il che mi rende veramente sta facendo
esattamente secondo me devo seguire
anche qui tipo il tragitto particolare
che non sto seguendo perché non ho visto
fogli posso dare fuoco i fogli di fiato
c'è un muro finto ci sono è una casa con
tutte le luci accese che figata io
pensavo fosse un horror questo non è un
horror poi un horror ancora visto niente
di spaventoso
grazie mi piacciono i gettoni salve la
barchetta minuscole o in giro mini jack
sparrow là dentro
buongiorno errori to condominio dove
hanno lasciato tutte le ore che sprecate
l'energia regalo usate le candele bravi
scusate le candele questa roba
c'è una festa mi invitate a me per corte
all i gettoni io oi gettoni posso
entrare questa roba è un enigma ma non
lo capisco
non so cosa voglia dire va beh non
importa dall'altra parte c'è una
ragnatela qualcuno pulisca per cortesia
fanno schifo i ragni buongiorno o gesù
cristo
allora giro destra devo fare tutto il
giro immagino no ragazzi abbiamo non
potete farmi fare è troppo difficile
aiuto sto girando gioco fai succedere
qualcosa sto girando vi prego non ho ben
capito cosa devi girare esternamente a
ok allora giorno invitate alla festa per
favore che mi piace essere la festa è
molto carino come gioco se non capisci
che si prova si sono chiuse le porte non
ci sono più porte aiuto sto girando in
tondo e strettissimo è diventato
strettissimo c'è solo un aiuto erano
stanza gigante prima e vabbè rai che ha
bisogno di averti sempre giocare a tanti
chamber ve lo ricordate anti chamber è
fighissimo dai dai dai fatevi aprì la
porta la prima volta cosa una festa a
sorpresa olio le sorprese se non ha
pensato sorpresa e ve lo dico la sorella
avrò apri ci sono siti di tutti
aiuto aprite prese qua orco schifo che
kakà sarà sono studiata bene sta roba
per fare qua aprite
la cascando un aeroplano
porca vacca loro ira i ragni no era
chiuso il gioco lo chiuso non ripartire
da capo ma no dai ti prego davvero le
ripartire da capo
ma no ho schiacciato escono schiacciare
i ragni di olio non ci posso fare niente
o rifarvi tutto va bene ragazzi siamo
tornati di nuovo qua finalmente dopo sei
ore che ce l'ho fatta ricca dell'aereo
non schiacciamo all'ultimo ciao marco
demonio ma che schifo ci sono regno
ovunque ma che schifo ciaoradio sul
soffitto
non devo schiacciare il tasto esca
orribile vabbè salve non guardare il
ragno non lo voglio guardare vai
tranquillo non lo qua non lo guardo io
non lo guardo e sono minimi mi fa le
cose
mammamia protocollo devo stare attento
non devo farmi questo vi è giusto che
schifo ragano effetto sonoro orribile ci
sono come faccia uscire è un labirinto
orribile dove sono allora qua anche
trento sono non saprei neanche dire dove
sono in questo istante quindi oh mio dio
orribile che schifo va bene ragazzi
andiamo al qui sotto e non facciamo non
guardiamo i ragni
noi guardiamo ok ho capito più o meno
come dovrebbe essere il tragitto però
non so se riuscirò mai a farlo mamma mia
ragazzi bruttissimo orribile non voglio
barca vacca che schifo semmai un ragno
del genere dovesse caparra e mamma mia
ragazzi bile e bruttissimo
mi ha fatto male ma che schifo io mi fa
schifo perché mi immagino io comunque
corso dietro orribile ragazzi andiamo
avanti
ok non dove non devo semplicemente far
sì che mi tocchi però è difficile perché
ci sta parte dove le voci mi ha mangiato
come vi fa ripartire dall'inizio che
palle non ci sono anche i check point
posso farcela posso fare la sua parte
difficilissima perché passa esattamente
qui dove mi serve aiuto e culo
vai vai veloce è difficilissimo non mi
ricordo più
non mi ricordo più dove devo andare
ragazzi aiuto può fare tutto questo giro
strano dai dai dai dai velocemente non
c'è perfetto perfetto perfetto effetto
non so se sei giusto ai ragazzi più o
meno perfetto vai vai vai vai vai ok ok
ok go a destra quale poi
[Musica]
ok ha dato via perfetto veloce veloce
velocissimo dolcissimo velocissimo
ora devo fare tutto un casino e andare
nel mezzo ok la vedo vedo riuscita alla
dell'uscita ok appena passa ci vado ci
vado ci vado del accessi sono fuori sono
fuori ho vinto sono forte sono forte
mamma mia
c'ho messo sei ore per falsa parte ur e
dammi la pagina
cos'è una ricetta per cucinare la pasta
cos'è pasta coi ragni pasta al luogo
questa roba
o che pagina intorno alla colonna va
bene
ho girato cos'è che vuoi non c'è più
cosa continua a girare l'ultima gira
giro sempre giro sempre lo cosa succede
ma devo tornare tipo ii può essere ok io
semplicemente constato sto girando da
mezz'ora invece dove tornerà va bene
fatto da adam khel
bravo a dan kelly gioco bellissimo meno
ragni però è bello però meno ragni però
bello
però meno ragni grazie ragazzi previsto
penombra questo era un gioco di adam
khel quello che fai ragni però che vi
sia per cento ragazzi che stava penombra
ragni version passato stravede per il
momento mi piace anche di socialità di
giustizia né sensato si siede e ci
vediamo l'anno prossimo ragno da ragazzi
[Musica]